back in 2012 physicists at the
University of Leicester published a
study in the Journal of special physics
topics they noted that after leaping
from a 150 meter high Gotham City
skyscraper Batman could realistically
Glide for approximately 350 meters on a
4.7 meter wingspan before the velocity
levels off at 110 kilometers per hour at
that point an 80 kilometer per hour
descent would begin causing the DC
Comics Mainstay to plummet to his death
unless he found something to break his
fall clearly gliding using a bat Cape is
not a safe way to travel still there's
nothing wrong with pretending that
Batman can use his cape to Glide from
building to building it's a fun mechanic
to use in the Batman Arkham video games
for example and it sets up some neat
visuals on the big screen